- Bienvenue dans Comprendre
l'information et le calcul quantiques.
Je m'appelle John Watrous et je suis directeur technique
pour IBM Quantum Education.
Ceci est la troisième leçon de la série. Dans les deux premières leçons, nous avons parlé des bases
de l'information quantique.
D'abord pour les systèmes individuels en isolation, puis pour les systèmes multiples.
Nous avons aussi discuté des mesures en base standard et des opérations unitaires, dans les contextes de systèmes simples et
de systèmes multiples.
Dans cette leçon, nous allons introduire
le modèle de quantum circuit, qui nous donne une façon standard de décrire les calculs quantiques,
et nous pouvons aussi utiliser les quantum circuits pour décrire des protocoles quantiques et d'autres types d'interactions impliquant plusieurs dispositifs quantiques.
En plus des quantum circuits, nous allons aussi discuter de quelques
concepts mathématiques importants liés à l'information quantique,
et nous les utiliserons pour observer
quelques limitations fondamentales de l'information quantique et de ce qu'on peut faire avec les quantum circuits.
Ça nous préparera bien pour
la leçon suivante où nous verrons quelques
exemples très importants et qui conclura la
première unité de la série
sur les bases de l'information quantique.
Voici un aperçu de la leçon. Nous commencerons par le modèle de quantum circuit et nous verrons comment il fonctionne.
Ensuite nous parlerons de
la notion cruciale de produit intérieur, ainsi que d'orthonormalité et de projections,
qui sont liées aux produits intérieurs. Nous n'avons pas discuté de ces choses
dans les deux premières leçons, parce que nous n'en avions
pas vraiment besoin, mais maintenant oui.
Les produits intérieurs nous fournissent
un outil mathématique dont nous ne pourrions tout simplement pas nous passer.
Nous n'irions simplement pas loin dans la compréhension de l'information quantique et du
calcul sans les produits intérieurs.
Et dans la troisième partie de la leçon, nous allons examiner quelques
limitations importantes de l'information quantique.
En fin de compte, ce que nous voulons faire c'est d'explorer des
choses intéressantes que nous pouvons faire avec l'information quantique, mais pour le faire efficacement,
nous devons être conscients de certaines
choses que nous ne pouvons pas faire.
En particulier, nous allons discuter
de la notion de phase globale et pourquoi les phases globales sont sans importance.
Nous verrons un énoncé
du théorème de non-clonage, qui nous dit que les états quantiques ne peuvent pas être copiés en général, et nous verrons que deux états quantiques
ne peuvent pas être
parfaitement distingués l'un de l'autre à moins d'être orthogonaux, ce qui est une limitation fondamentale dont il faut être conscient.
Le premier sujet de la leçon
est le modèle de quantum circuit, qui est un modèle de calcul
qui nous fournit une façon
de décrire les calculs quantiques.
Le modèle de quantum circuit est
basé sur une notion plus générale en informatique de circuit, et tu peux définir beaucoup
de différents modèles de calcul
basés sur cette notion générale.
L'idée de base est qu'un
circuit est composé de fils qui transportent de l'information, et de gates, qui représentent des opérations
qui sont appliquées à
l'information transportée par les fils.
Le terme circuit est en fait
un nom assez étrange à utiliser pour ce type de modèle
parce que le mot circuit
désigne habituellement un
chemin circulaire d'une certaine sorte.
Mais quand nous parlons de circuits
comme modèles de calcul, nous parlons généralement
de circuits acycliques
où les chemins circulaires ne sont pas autorisés.
Pour être plus précis, pour les
besoins de cette série, nous allons exiger que
l'information circule toujours de gauche à droite dans tout circuit.
Donc si tu préfères, tu
peux penser aux circuits comme décrivant des séquences d'opérations où le temps va de gauche à droite.
Voici un exemple d'un circuit booléen où les fils transportent des
valeurs binaires, soit zéro soit un,
et les gates représentent
des opérations de logique booléenne.
Les fils sont représentés par des lignes, et ici nous avons deux bits d'entrée
étiquetés X et Y,
et si tu veux savoir
ce que le circuit fait pour un choix particulier d'entrées, tu propageas les valeurs sur
les fils de gauche à droite,
en fonction des actions
que les gates ont sur les valeurs qui sont
transportées par les fils.
Donc par exemple, on peut
regarder ce qui se passe quand on commence avec le fil d'entrée du haut mis à la valeur un et le fil d'entrée du bas
mis à la valeur zéro.
Ces deux fils d'entrée mènent
à ces deux points ici, qui représentent des opérations de fan-out, ce qui signifie que la valeur est copiée
pour qu'elle puisse être portée
en avant sur plusieurs fils.
Donc si on fait ça, alors ces
deux fils prennent la valeur un, qui est la même que ce un, et ces deux fils prennent la valeur zéro,
qui est la même que ce zéro.
Ici on a un gate NOT qui
est indiqué par le symbole de la négation logique, donc la
valeur qui sort est un zéro,
qui est la négation logique de un. Et similairement, la valeur
qui sort de ce gate est un qui est la
négation logique de zéro.
Ces deux gates sont des gates AND,
ce gate est un gate OR, et si on continue
et qu'on propage les valeurs
WEBVTT
à travers le circuit, en évaluant
les gates de manière appropriée, on voit que la valeur finale
sur ce fil ici est un.
Donc le circuit entier décrit
une séquence d'opérations qui sont composées comme la figure le suggère, et on obtient une fonction
de deux bits vers un bit
dans ce cas particulier. Mais en général, il pourrait y avoir n'importe quel nombre
de bits d'entrée et de sortie.
Ce circuit particulier calcule le OU exclusif des deux bits d'entrée, donc la sortie est un
si et seulement si exactement
un des deux bits d'entrée est mis à un et l'autre est mis à zéro, mais ce n'est pas vraiment
important, c'est juste un exemple.
C'est un fait de base sur les circuits booléens que toute fonction de n'importe quel nombre de bits vers n'importe quel nombre de bits peut être calculée
par un certain circuit booléen, bien que parfois tu aies besoin
d'un très grand circuit pour calculer la fonction
qui t'intéresse.
Il existe d'autres styles qui
sont utilisés pour décrire les circuits.
Par exemple, cette figure
représente exactement le même circuit qu'avant, en utilisant un style peut-être plus typique
en génie électrique, où il y a des conventions pour les formes qui représentent différents gates.
Nous n'allons pas utiliser
ce style particulier, mais nous allons introduire
quelques symboles à nous pour différents quantum gates, comme les gates Hadamard,
les gates Controlled NOT,
les gates Toffoli, et ainsi de suite.
Juste comme aparté, ici on peut voir l'origine
du terme circuit.
Dans le contexte du génie électrique, il est très naturel de
penser à l'électricité circulant dans un circuit.
Mais dans cette série nous ne
parlons pas d'électricité se déplaçant dans des circuits, nous parlons d'information
se déplaçant dans des circuits.
Et encore une fois pour nous, ils seront toujours acycliques, où l'information
se déplace de gauche à droite.
Voici un exemple différent d'un
type différent de circuit appelé circuit arithmétique.
Cette fois les fils stockent des nombres et les gates représentent
des opérations arithmétiques comme l'addition et la multiplication.
Ici tu peux voir un exemple
d'un circuit arithmétique.
Ce n'est pas important pour les besoins
de cette leçon ce qu'il fait, c'est juste un exemple qui est
censé transmettre l'idée qu'il existe différentes
notions de circuits.
On peut aussi penser à
des circuits impliquant du hasard, par exemple, où les gates représentent
des opérations probabilistes, et si tu en avais envie,
tu pourrais probablement passer la journée à inventer de nouveaux modèles de calcul basés sur la notion de circuits.
Dans le modèle de quantum circuit,
les fils représentent des Qubits, et les gates représentent à la fois des opérations unitaires et des mesures.
Voici un exemple très simple
d'un quantum circuit.
Il n'y a qu'un seul Qubit dans ce circuit, qui est représenté
par la ligne horizontale, et les gates, qui sont
indiqués par des carrés,
représentent des opérations unitaires qui sont effectuées sur ce Qubit.
Il n'y a donc pas de mesures
dans cet exemple particulier.
Si on veut donner au
Qubit un nom comme X, on peut l'indiquer dans le diagramme en mettant un X ici
même, c'est optionnel.
Tout comme pour le circuit booléen de tout à l'heure, on peut penser à ce circuit
comme représentant une séquence d'opérations où le temps
va de gauche à droite.
Donc on commence avec X,
on applique le premier gate, qui est un gate Hadamard
suivi d'un gate S,
puis un autre gate Hadamard
et enfin un gate T.
Nous avons vu ces opérations
vers la fin de la leçon un, et ici tu peux voir
leurs descriptions matricielles.
Donc quand on effectue ces
quatre opérations dans l'ordre, ce qui signifie d'abord H, puis
S, puis H de nouveau, et puis T,
l'opération combinée est donnée
par ce produit ici, en gardant à l'esprit que l'ordre
est essentiellement inversé
comme nous en avons parlé dans la leçon un. Si on effectue la multiplication matricielle, on obtient cette matrice ici,
et donc l'action du
circuit sur le Qubit X est décrite par cette matrice unitaire.
Parfois on aimerait indiquer explicitement dans un diagramme de quantum circuit
quelle entrée on fournit, et on peut le faire comme tu le vois ici.
Dans ce cas, on entre
Ket 0 dans le circuit.
C'est assez courant. On prend souvent Ket 0 comme
l'état initialisé d'un Qubit, mais ce n'est pas obligatoire.
On pourrait aussi envisager
d'appliquer le circuit à un état différent.
Si on le choisit, on peut aussi
indiquer l'état de sortie qu'on obtient comme ça.
Voici un autre exemple où
cette fois nous avons deux Qubits nommés X et Y comme tu
peux le voir dans le diagramme.
Ici nous avons un gate Hadamard, qui est appliqué au Qubit Y, suivi par le gate indiqué par
ce symbole ici,
qui est un gate Controlled NOT. Nous avons parlé de l'opération
Controlled NOT dans la leçon précédente,
et ici dans ce diagramme on
peut voir que le Qubit de contrôle est Y, qui est indiqué par
le petit cercle rempli,
et le Qubit cible est X, qui est indiqué par le grand cercle avec ce qui ressemble à un signe plus dedans.
Ça ressemble un peu au
symbole du OU exclusif donc c'est logique.
WEBVTT
Tu peux imaginer que quel que soit
l'état classique stocké dans Y, il est XORé sur le Qubit X.
Et juste par souci de clarté, voici le diagramme qui
montre l'action de ce gate sur les états de la base standard,
où on suppose que A
et B sont des valeurs binaires.
Pour d'autres états, l'action est déterminée
par la linéarité comme toujours.
Maintenant, avant d'aller plus loin, il sera utile de
formuler explicitement une convention que nous allons suivre concernant comment les Qubits sont ordonnés
dans les diagrammes de quantum circuit comme celui-ci.
Et la convention est que
l'ordre de bas en haut dans un diagramme de quantum circuit est équivalent à l'ordre de gauche à droite
comme dans un tuple ou un produit tensoriel.
C'est une convention que nous allons
suivre dans la série et c'est aussi la convention
utilisée dans Qiskit.
Donc pour ce circuit particulier ici, nous pensons à lui comme
agissant sur une paire de Qubits X, Y,
X vient en premier parce qu'il est en bas, et Y vient en dernier ou en deuxième dans ce cas, parce qu'il est en haut.
La façon dont tu peux penser à ça
visuellement, au cas où ça aiderait, c'est d'imaginer faire tourner
ce circuit dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre pour que les entrées soient en haut
et les sorties soient en bas, et l'ordre des
Qubits sera correct.
Parfois cet ordre perturbe les gens, donc assure-toi de garder
cette convention à l'esprit.
Donc quand on pense à l'action que ce circuit décrit, ce qu'on a d'abord c'est un
gate Hadamard appliqué à Y
et ensuite un gate Controlled NOT
sur les deux Qubits avec Y comme contrôle
et X comme cible.
Si on veut écrire une matrice unitaire qui décrit l'action combinée
de ces deux gates, on peut le faire.
D'abord, on considère le gate Hadamard sur Y.
On applique le gate Hadamard à Y et on ne fait rien à X, ce qui est équivalent à
effectuer une opération identité sur X.
Et donc l'action du gate Hadamard sur les deux Qubits ensemble est
donnée par le produit tensoriel de la matrice identité et
de la matrice représentant
l'opération Hadamard sur Y.
Ça ressemble à ça, en gardant à l'esprit notre
convention que X vient en premier et Y vient en second, donc c'est
l'identité tensoirisée avec H.
Ensuite on applique
l'opération Controlled NOT, qui a cette représentation matricielle, et encore une fois, c'est cohérent avec notre convention.
Le deuxième Qubit Y est le contrôle et le premier Qubit X est la cible.
N'hésite pas à mettre la vidéo en pause et vérifier que ça a du sens, et j'arrêterai de te le rappeler.
Tu peux mettre ces vidéos en pause, revenir en arrière et regarder des parties
autant de fois que tu veux, ajuster la vitesse de lecture si tu le choisis, les utiliser de la façon qui
te convient le mieux.
Bref, quand on compose les
deux opérations ensemble, l'action combinée est décrite
par ce produit ici,
et ces deux matrices sont
multipliées dans cet ordre parce que le Hadamard est effectué en premier et le Controlled NOT
est effectué en second,
et encore une fois, c'est cohérent
avec ce dont nous avons parlé dans la leçon un où l'ordre
est essentiellement inversé.
Si on effectue la multiplication matricielle, on obtient cette matrice ici.
Et on peut maintenant lire depuis cette matrice ce que le circuit fait aux
états de la base standard.
Si on exécute le circuit sur l'entrée 0, 0, c'est-à-dire Ket 0 pour le premier Qubit, Ket 0 pour le deuxième Qubit,
le résultat est l'état de Bell Phi+, qu'on peut voir dans la
première colonne de la matrice.
Si on entre 0, 1, on obtient l'état Phi-, un zéro nous donne l'état Si+,
et 1, 1 nous donne non pas Psi-, mais -1 X Psi-.
Le signe moins n'est pas
vraiment important ici. Si tu ne voulais pas l'avoir ici, tu pourrais effectuer une opération swap
sur les deux Qubits
pour s'en débarrasser et tu
ne perturberais pas ce qui s'est passé pour les trois premiers états de la base standard.
Mais ce n'est vraiment pas important
pour les besoins de cet exemple.
Donc en résumé, le circuit a cette action ici sur les états de la base standard.
Quand tu penses à
ce que fait un circuit particulier, tu n'as pas besoin de passer par
la conversion en matrices et de les multiplier ensemble,
tu peux aussi tracer
l'action que le circuit a sur des états particuliers, et dans de nombreux cas ce sera
l'option préférée.
Dans cet exemple, par exemple, on peut voir ce que le circuit
fait à l'état 0, 0 en examinant l'action des gates.
L'état initial, que
nous avons nommé Pi zéro ici, juste pour éviter un nom
qui serait confusant avec les états de Bell, est 0, 0.
On applique le gate Hadamard et l'état qu'on obtient est 0+ qu'on peut développer comme ça,
et ensuite l'opération Controlled NOT amène cet état à l'état Phi+, qu'on peut voir en pensant
à l'action que le Controlled NOT a sur
les états de la base standard,
Et tu peux faire la même chose
pour les trois autres états de la base standard ou n'importe quel
autre état d'ailleurs.
On peut aussi incorporer des bits classiques dans les diagrammes de quantum circuit.
Ils sont indiqués par
des lignes doubles comme tu le vois dans ce diagramme.
C'est-à-dire que A et B sont des bits classiques et X et Y sont des Qubits.
WEBVTT
Nous avons les deux mêmes gates unitaires que dans l'exemple précédent, et ces symboles ici représentent des mesures en base standard
Plus précisément, après que les deux
opérations unitaires sont effectuées, une mesure en base standard
est effectuée sur Y
et le résultat est écrasé
dans le bit classique, B, et de même X est mesuré et le résultat est écrit dans le bit A.
Ici tu peux voir que les Qubits X et Y continuent après qu'ils sont mesurés.
C'est assez courant
cependant que nous nous soucions peu des Qubits
après qu'ils sont mesurés.
Parfois tout ce qui nous intéresse
c'est le résultat de la mesure. Et dans un cas comme ça, on peut utiliser le style abrégé que tu vois ici
où les mesures ont des Qubits en entrée et des bits classiques en sortie.
La compréhension ici est que
une fois les Qubits mesurés, ils sont simplement rejetés ou ignorés et le résultat classique de la mesure
est porté en avant.
Maintenant, au fur et à mesure que la série continue, nous verrons beaucoup
d'exemples de quantum circuits et ils seront généralement
beaucoup plus compliqués que les exemples très simples
que nous venons de voir.
Comme je l'ai mentionné plus tôt, différents symboles sont
utilisés pour différents gates.
Les gates à Qubit unique sont généralement
juste écrits comme des carrés avec une lettre indiquant
quelle opération c'est.
Parfois ces différents
gates sont codés par couleur pour signifier différentes choses, mais
nous ignorerons ça pour l'instant.
Nous avons déjà vu le
gate Controlled NOT.
Les gates Swap sont dénotés
comme tu le vois ici, Et les gates Toffoli et les gates Fredkin
sont dénotés comme tu le vois ici.
Rappelle-toi qu'un gate Toffoli est un gate Controlled Controlled NOT et qu'un gate Fredkin est
un gate swap contrôlé.
Donc ces symboles sont
cohérents avec l'idée qu'un Qubit de contrôle est
indiqué par un cercle plein avec une ligne le reliant
au gate qu'il contrôle.
En général, les Qubits contrôlés
n'ont pas besoin d'être en haut et ces gates n'ont pas
à agir sur des Qubits voisins, ce qui signifie que ces gates
peuvent s'étirer sur
d'autres Qubits sur lesquels ils n'agissent pas, et nous verrons ça
se produire dans les leçons futures.
Une autre chose que nous faisons souvent quand nous utilisons le modèle de quantum circuit est de voir des opérations unitaires arbitraires
sur n'importe quel nombre de Qubits
comme si elles sont des gates uniques comme tu le vois ici.
Juste en dessinant un rectangle avec une étiquette correspondant
à quelle que soit l'opération unitaire c'est.
Dans ce cas c'est une
opération unitaire U quelconque.
Bien sûr, nous ne savons pas
ce qu'est U depuis ce diagramme, nous devons supposer que
U est défini d'une certaine façon ou que nous considérons une
opération unitaire U arbitraire, peut-être. Ça pourrait être par exemple que
nous voulons juste penser à U comme à une sous-routine dans
un souci de clarté.
Nous utilisons aussi cette notation
que tu vois ici pour une opération U contrôlée
où le Qubit de contrôle est indiqué par un cercle plein
tout comme nous avions avant.
Donc c'est une brève introduction
au modèle de quantum circuit. Et comme je l'ai dit avant, nous verrons beaucoup plus
d'exemples de quantum circuits
au fur et à mesure que nous continuons dans la série.
Dans la prochaine partie de la leçon, nous allons
examiner les produits intérieurs, l'orthonormalité et les projections, qui sont des notions très importantes
en information quantique et calcul.
Nous commencerons par les produits intérieurs.
Rappelle-toi que quand nous
utilisons la notation directe, un Ket est un vecteur colonne
et un Bra est un vecteur ligne,
et plus précisément le
vecteur Bra correspondant à un vecteur colonne donné est la transposée conjuguée
de ce vecteur colonne.
Donc pour ce vecteur ici, on obtient le vecteur Bra correspondant en transposant le vecteur
comme s'il s'agissait d'une matrice,
ce qui revient à le coucher sur le côté puis à prendre le conjugué complexe de chacune des entrées.
Maintenant, supposons que nous ayons deux Kets avec le même nombre d'entrées comme ça.
Si on forme ce bracket ici, ce qui signifie simplement qu'on
prend le produit du Bra et du Ket,
comme s'ils étaient des matrices,
alors on obtient cette expression
que tu vois ici, qui est un scalaire, ou en
d'autres termes un nombre complexe.
Cette valeur est appelée le produit intérieur
de ces deux vecteurs.
Tu peux aussi penser aux produits intérieurs en termes de vecteurs de la
forme que tu vois ici où les vecteurs sont exprimés
comme des combinaisons linéaires
de vecteurs de la base standard.
Le produit intérieur de ces vecteurs est défini de la même façon qu'
avant, Bra Psi fois Ket Phi qu'on peut exprimer
comme un produit comme ça.
Et si on calcule et simplifie, on obtient cette expression ici pour le produit intérieur, qui est analogue à ce qu'on avait avant,
sauf que cette fois nous
prenons la somme sur les éléments de notre ensemble d'états classiques, qui est sigma dans ce cas particulier.
Voici un exemple censé te donner une image géométrique de
comment fonctionnent les produits intérieurs.
Ici j'ai dessiné un cercle
dans un espace bidimensionnel correspondant à un Qubit, et tant que nous limitons notre attention
aux vecteurs ayant des entrées de nombres réels, nous pouvons les dessiner comme des points sur ce plan.
WEBVTT
Prenons Phi comme
ce vecteur ici.
C'est un vecteur unitaire, ce qu'on peut voir en
calculant la norme euclidienne et c'est ce que représente ce cercle,
c'est l'ensemble de tous les vecteurs unitaires
ayant des entrées de nombres réels.
Disons aussi que Psi est
ce vecteur ici, qui est également un vecteur unitaire.
C'est l'état moins en fait, mais ici nous l'appelons juste Psi.
Si on calcule le produit intérieur
de ces deux vecteurs, on obtient un moins la racine carrée de trois sur deux fois racine de deux,
ce qui est approximativement -1/4.
La valeur de ce produit intérieur est égale au cosinus de l'angle
entre les deux vecteurs, comme tu peux le voir ici dans la figure.
C'est quelque chose qui est
généralement vrai pour les vecteurs unitaires. Si nous avons deux vecteurs unitaires et qu'ils ont tous deux des entrées de nombres réels,
alors le produit intérieur entre eux est égal au cosinus de
l'angle entre eux.
En particulier, si le produit intérieur
est égal à zéro, comme dans cet exemple, où nous avons changé Psi pour
être cet état ici,
alors les deux vecteurs doivent
être à un angle de 90 degrés l'un par rapport à l'autre.
Tout ça se généralise à
des vecteurs dans n'importe quelle dimension, d'ailleurs, tant que les
entrées sont des nombres réels, ce n'est pas juste pour les vecteurs bidimensionnels.
Si nous avons des entrées de nombres complexes, l'image ne fonctionne plus vraiment, mais néanmoins, le produit intérieur est tout aussi
utile comme nous le verrons.
Le produit intérieur a quelques
propriétés très importantes et nous allons prendre quelques instants pour observer certaines de ces propriétés maintenant.
D'abord, il y a une connexion
entre le produit intérieur et la norme euclidienne.
Si on prend le produit intérieur
de n'importe quel vecteur avec lui-même, on obtient la norme euclidienne au carré.
Donc on peut dire alternativement que la norme euclidienne d'un vecteur est égale à la racine
carrée du produit intérieur
de ce vecteur avec lui-même. Ce n'est pas une coïncidence, c'est
une connexion fondamentale, et ici on peut voir que si nous n'avions pas
les conjugués complexes dans la définition du produit intérieur, alors cette formule
ne serait plus vraie, et nous n'aurions pas une telle notion utile
avec cette connexion fondamentale
à la norme euclidienne.
Ensuite, le produit intérieur
est conjugué symétrique, ce qui signifie que si on échange
l'ordre des deux arguments, alors la valeur qu'on obtient pour le
produit intérieur est conjuguée.
C'est exprimé par
cette équation ici et il est assez simple de voir pourquoi cela se produit pour ces deux expressions
pour le produit intérieur des deux vecteurs dans les deux ordres possibles.
Le produit intérieur est linéaire
dans le second argument. Plus précisément, si on définit un vecteur Phi comme étant cette combinaison linéaire de deux vecteurs,
Phi un et Phi deux, alors le produit intérieur de
n'importe quel vecteur Psi avec Phi est la même combinaison linéaire
des deux produits intérieurs,
et ça découle assez
directement du fait que la multiplication matricielle est linéaire.
Et on a aussi que le produit intérieur
est conjugué linéaire dans le premier argument, comme tu peux le voir exprimé ici.
Si Psi est cette combinaison linéaire
de vecteurs, alors si on prend le produit intérieur
de Psi et Phi,
alors Bra Psi devient ce vecteur que l'on voit ici où on prend le conjugué complexe
de bêta un et bêta deux,
et donc c'est le résultat et c'est ce qu'on entend
par linéarité conjuguée.
Et la dernière propriété du produit intérieur que je veux mentionner est
l'inégalité de Cauchy-Schwarz incroyablement utile.
Pour deux vecteurs quelconques, Psi et Phi, la valeur absolue du produit intérieur ne peut jamais être plus grande que le
produit des normes euclidiennes
des deux vecteurs. Et de plus, la seule façon que les deux
côtés de l'inégalité puissent être égaux c'est si les deux
vecteurs sont linéairement dépendants,
ce qui signifie que l'un d'eux est égal à un certain scalaire fois l'autre.
C'est en fait l'une des
inégalités les plus largement utilisées dans toutes les mathématiques et
nous l'utilisons encore et encore quand nous parlons d'information quantique,
donc c'est très bon de la connaître.
Ensuite, nous parlerons des
notions d'orthogonalité et d'orthonormalité qui sont
liées aux produits intérieurs
et plus précisément, avec
des produits intérieurs de vecteurs étant égaux à zéro.
Pour être précis, si nous avons
deux vecteurs, Psi et Phi, nous disons qu'ils sont orthogonaux
si leur produit intérieur
est égal à zéro. Et la façon dont on peut penser
aux vecteurs orthogonaux intuitivement c'est qu'ils sont
à angle droit l'un par rapport à l'autre,
ou alternativement, qu'ils sont
perpendiculaires l'un à l'autre.
Les gens utilisent parfois le terme orthogonal pour désigner des choses qui n'ont
rien à voir l'une avec l'autre, comme dire qu'une question
est orthogonale à une autre,
mais c'est évidemment assez informel et pas vraiment significatif
au sens mathématique, mais la connexion est claire si tu penses aux vecteurs orthogonaux comme pointant
non pas dans des directions opposées, mais dans des directions complètement différentes comme le nord versus l'ouest par exemple.
Si nous avons un ensemble de vecteurs, nous disons que l'ensemble est un ensemble orthogonal si deux vecteurs distincts quelconques
choisis dans cet ensemble
sont nécessairement orthogonaux l'un à l'autre, ce qu'on peut exprimer
comme tu le vois ici,
WEBVTT
Un ensemble orthonormal est
simplement un ensemble orthogonal de vecteurs unitaires.
Les vecteurs dans les ensembles orthogonaux
n'ont pas nécessairement besoin d'être des vecteurs unitaires, et en fait tu pourrais
même avoir le vecteur zéro
comme élément d'un ensemble orthogonal, mais dans un ensemble orthonormal, chaque vecteur doit être un vecteur unitaire
en plus de
l'exigence que l'ensemble est un ensemble orthogonal.
Étant donné ce que nous savons sur la relation entre le produit intérieur
et la norme euclidienne, on peut exprimer cette
condition de manière assez succincte
comme tu le vois ici.
Et finalement, une base orthonormale est simplement un ensemble orthonormal
qui forme une base pour quel que soit l'espace vectoriel
dont nous parlons.
Par exemple, si on prend n'importe quel
ensemble d'états classiques sigma et qu'on pense à l'ensemble de
tous les vecteurs de la base standard,
on voit que c'est un ensemble orthonormal et en fait c'est une base orthonormale pour l'espace de tous les vecteurs dont les entrées correspondent à
cet ensemble d'états classiques sigma.
Ce sont tous des vecteurs unitaires et
ils sont orthogonaux deux à deux, donc c'est un ensemble orthonormal.
et parce que c'est aussi une base, nous avons que c'est une base orthonormale.
Les ensembles orthonormaux sont
toujours linéairement indépendants d'ailleurs, donc à chaque fois qu'on a
un ensemble orthonormal, ce sera toujours une base orthonormale pour un sous-espace quelconque,
mais dans ce cas, nous avons une base pour l'espace entier avec lequel nous travaillons.
Un autre exemple est l'ensemble
contenant Ket+ et Ket-.
Ces deux vecteurs sont orthogonaux, leur produit intérieur est égal à zéro.
et ils sont tous deux des vecteurs unitaires et ils couvrent l'espace
bidimensionnel de vecteurs correspondant à un seul Qubit, donc ils forment une base orthonormale
pour cet espace.
Un autre exemple est la base de Bell, qui est une base orthonormale pour l'espace de tous
les vecteurs à quatre dimensions correspondant à deux Qubits.
L'ensemble contenant Ket 0
et Ket+ en revanche, n'est pas un ensemble orthogonal parce que le produit intérieur entre
ces vecteurs est non nul.
Ce sont tous deux des vecteurs unitaires et c'est une base pour l'espace vectoriel correspondant à un Qubit, mais nous n'avons pas l'orthogonalité.
Voici un fait pratique sur les ensembles orthonormaux que nous utiliserons de temps en temps.
Supposons que nous ayons un
ensemble orthonormal de vecteurs, plus précisément, supposons
que nous ayons M vecteurs dans cet ensemble, Psi un à Psi M,
où nous supposons que ces vecteurs sont tirés d'un espace vectoriel
de dimension N, ou en d'autres termes, chacun des
vecteurs a M entrées.
Comme je l'ai déjà mentionné, les ensembles orthonormaux sont toujours
linéairement indépendants, donc il ne peut pas être que M soit plus grand que N,
mais il pourrait être que M est plus petit que N, et c'est le cas qui
nous intéresse.
Et ce que le fait énonce c'est
que si M est plus petit que N, alors il est toujours possible
d'ajouter des vecteurs supplémentaires
à l'ensemble avec lequel on a commencé afin d'obtenir une
base orthonormale pour notre espace.
Pour être précis, il doit
nécessairement exister des vecteurs Psi M+1 jusqu'à Psi N de sorte que l'ensemble entier
forme une base orthonormale.
Donc tu ne peux jamais te retrouver
dans une impasse, pour ainsi dire, en choisissant d'une certaine façon un
ensemble orthonormal de vecteurs qui ne peut pas être étendu pour
former une base orthonormale.
Parfois tu peux juste regarder
l'ensemble avec lequel tu commences et comprendre comment l'étendre pour former une base orthonormale, mais une alternative qui fonctionne toujours
est d'utiliser une procédure connue sous le nom de processus d'orthonormalisation de Gram-Schmidt
pour construire ces vecteurs.
Je n'expliquerai pas cette
procédure dans cette leçon ni dans cette série car les détails ne sont
pas vraiment importants pour nous, mais bien sûr tu peux
la chercher si tu es curieux.
C'est quelque chose qui peut
être effectué par un ordinateur au cas où c'est pertinent, donc
il n'y a pas de créativité impliquée, c'est juste une procédure mécanique.
L'une des raisons pour lesquelles c'est
un fait si pratique à avoir est liée à la connexion étroite qui existe entre les bases orthonormales
et les matrices unitaires.
En particulier, pour toute matrice carrée U, les trois conditions que tu vois ici sont toujours équivalentes,
ce qui signifie qu'elles sont soit
toutes vraies soit toutes fausses.
La première condition dit
que U est une matrice unitaire, ce qui signifie que U dague fois U et U fois U dague sont toutes deux
égales à la matrice identité.
La deuxième condition
dit que les lignes de U forment une base orthonormale
et la troisième condition dit que les colonnes de U
forment une base orthonormale.
Ce n'est en fait pas trop difficile
de voir pourquoi cette équivalence est vraie.
Juste pour garder les choses simples, regardons une
matrice U trois par trois comme tu le vois ici, où les entrées peuvent être n'importe quels
nombres complexes que tu veux.
Ici sur le côté gauche j'ai écrit U transposée conjuguée
juste par commodité.
Si on forme trois vecteurs
à partir des colonnes de U, qui ici sont nommés Psi
un, Psi deux et Psi trois, alors si on prend le
produit de U dague et U,
tu peux vérifier que chaque
entrée du produit est donnée par un produit intérieur de vecteurs comme on le voit ici dans ce motif.
Et maintenant quand tu penses à la condition que U est unitaire, ce qui est équivalent à cette matrice étant égale à la matrice identité,
tu vois que c'est équivalent
aux trois vecteurs formant un ensemble orthonormal.
Les entrées diagonales doivent toutes
être égales à un, donc ce sont nécessairement des vecteurs unitaires, et les entrées hors diagonale
doivent être zéro,
donc c'est un ensemble orthogonal de vecteurs.
WEBVTT
Donc U étant unitaire est équivalent aux colonnes formant un ensemble orthonormal,
Et ça doit être une base parce que le nombre de vecteurs dans l'ensemble, qui est trois dans ce cas, correspond à la dimension de l'espace
avec lequel on travaille. Tu peux suivre un argument similaire pour les lignes au lieu des colonnes pour conclure que U étant
unitaire est équivalent
aux lignes formant une base orthonormale.
Ça ne fonctionne pas tout à fait aussi bien parce que nous devons faire un ajustement pour que les conjugués complexes
fonctionnent de la bonne façon, mais l'idée est la même.
Une autre façon de procéder, qui est assez simple, est de prouver qu'une matrice est unitaire si et seulement si sa transposée est unitaire.
Et ici je veux bien dire transposée et non transposée conjuguée.
C'est assez trivial depuis la
définition des matrices unitaires, que la transposée conjuguée
de toute matrice unitaire est unitaire,
mais c'est aussi le cas que la transposée de toute matrice unitaire est unitaire.
En tout cas, nous avons l'
équivalence entre ces trois conditions sur toute matrice carrée U, et on peut combiner cette équivalence
avec le fait sur
l'extension des ensembles orthonormaux pour former des bases orthonormales afin de proposer des matrices unitaires
qui font des choses intéressantes
ou répondent à divers besoins que nous pourrions rencontrer.
Plus précisément, à chaque fois qu'on
a un ensemble orthonormal de M vecteurs, il existera toujours une matrice unitaire U
dont les M premières colonnes sont les vecteurs de cet ensemble orthonormal.
Les colonnes restantes
peuvent toujours être remplies de sorte qu'on obtienne une matrice unitaire en les choisissant de sorte que les colonnes forment
une base orthonormale. Ce sera un fait assez
pratique à avoir à notre disposition.
Et encore un sujet pour
cette section de la leçon est la notion de projection.
Une matrice carrée Pi est
dite être une projection ou une matrice de projection si les deux propriétés qui
sont listées ici sont toutes deux vraies.
C'est un Pi majuscule d'ailleurs, c'est un choix assez typique pour une lettre qui est utilisée pour désigner une projection.
Nous donnons souvent ces noms typiques à des objets comme les matrices juste pour les rendre plus faciles à reconnaître et garder les choses claires,
mais tu peux utiliser n'importe quel nom que tu veux. Bref, la première condition est que Pi est égal à sa propre transposée conjuguée.
En général, quand nous avons une matrice qui est égale à sa propre
transposée conjuguée, nous disons que c'est une matrice hermitienne.
Donc la première condition peut alternativement être énoncée comme Pi est hermitien.
La deuxième condition est
que si on élève Pi au carré, ce qui signifie qu'on multiplie Pi
par lui-même, on obtient Pi de nouveau.
Donc élever Pi au carré ne lui fait rien.
L'idée d'une projection
intuitivement parlant est qu'elle est similaire en
esprit à projeter une image sur un écran ou à abaisser
une perpendiculaire sur une ligne
par exemple. Quand tu multiplies un
vecteur par une projection, ce que tu fais c'est en quelque sorte
laisser une partie de lui tranquille
et annuler le reste.
Donc si tu appliques une
projection une deuxième fois, ça ne fait rien parce que
tu as déjà annulé la partie que la projection annule.
Un exemple de projection
est cette matrice ici pour n'importe quel choix d'un vecteur unitaire Psi.
On peut vérifier qu'elle satisfait
les conditions requises une par une.
Pour la première, on calcule
la transposée conjuguée et c'est la transposée conjuguée
d'un produit.
Et donc on peut utiliser cette formule ici pour la transposée conjuguée
d'un produit pour nous aider.
Ce qu'on obtient c'est le produit
des transposées conjuguées, mais l'ordre est inversé.
Ça arrive à cause de
la partie transposition.
Donc si on applique cette formule, on obtient cette égalité ici et on peut ensuite simplifier pour
revenir à la matrice originale.
Remarque d'ailleurs que nous n'avons pas utilisé le fait
que Psi est un vecteur unitaire.
Donc en fait, cette matrice est
hermitienne pour n'importe quel vecteur Psi, pas seulement pour les vecteurs unitaires.
Et pour la deuxième, on élève Pi au carré et on obtient
cette expression ici et c'est égal à la
matrice originale cette fois
parce que Psi est un vecteur unitaire, donc ce produit intérieur
ici est égal à un et c'est là qu'intervient l'hypothèse
que Psi est un vecteur unitaire
entre en jeu.
On peut généraliser cet exemple et commencer avec un ensemble orthonormal.
Et si on forme cette matrice ici, où on somme les projections correspondant aux vecteurs individuels, alors on obtient une projection.
Ici sur l'écran, tu peux voir les calculs qui révèlent cela et je te laisse les
examiner si tu le souhaites.
Et dans la même veine
que le premier exemple, c'est la deuxième condition où l'orthonormalité
de l'ensemble est utilisée.
Ce que fait cette projection si
tu la multiplies à un vecteur, c'est de projeter ce
vecteur sur le sous-espace qui est engendré par cet ensemble de vecteurs,
ce qui de manière abstraite est
comme abaisser une perpendiculaire à ce sous-espace, et une fois
que tu es dans ce sous-espace, la projection ne fait rien.
Donc les matrices comme ça sont
des exemples de projections, et maintenant en fait nous avons épuisé
toutes les possibilités.
Chaque matrice de projection prend cette forme pour un certain choix d'un ensemble orthonormal.
La matrice zéro est une projection, donc nous devons nous assurer de
l'inclure si on veut avoir toutes les projections.
WEBVTT
Donc juste pour être clair à ce sujet, nous permettons la
possibilité que M égale zéro et ça nous donne une somme vide,
que nous pouvons interpréter comme la matrice zéro.
Maintenant que nous avons le
concept de projection à notre disposition, nous pouvons définir une classe plus générale
de mesures quantiques connues sous le nom de mesures projectives.
Ce n'est pas la notion la plus générale
d'une mesure, mais c'est significativement plus général que les mesures en base standard
et ça va être très
utile d'intégrer ça dans notre description
de l'information quantique.
Une mesure projective est définie par n'importe quel ensemble de projections
qui satisfait la condition que tu vois ici, qui est que les projections
s'additionnent à la matrice identité.
Ici M peut être n'importe quel
entier positif que tu veux tant que ce sont toutes des projections et que cette condition est vraie,
la collection définit une
mesure projective.
La mesure décrite
par une telle collection fonctionne comme suit quand tu
mesures n'importe quel état quantique Psi.
D'abord tu obtiens un résultat
entre un et M, où M est le nombre de projections.
Pour chaque résultat possible, K, la probabilité d'obtenir ce résultat est la norme euclidienne
au carré du vecteur qu'on obtient
en multipliant S par Pi
K, la K-ième projection.
On peut aussi écrire cette
quantité comme tu le vois ici.
Cette égalité vient de la relation entre la norme euclidienne
et le produit intérieur, ainsi que du fait
que Pi K est une projection.
À partir de la deuxième forme, ainsi que de la condition que nous avons sur ces projections, on peut voir tout de suite, par linéarité, que nos probabilités
s'additionneront toujours à un,
en gardant à l'esprit que Psi
doit être un vecteur unitaire.
Et deuxièmement, en supposant que
nous obtenons le résultat, K, l'état du système
s'effondre vers l'état quantique qu'on obtient en normalisant quel que soit
le vecteur qu'on a obtenu par projection.
Nous allons regarder quelques
exemples dans un instant, mais avant, laisse-moi mentionner que nous n'avons pas vraiment besoin
de numéroter les résultats possibles
de un à M. Nous pouvons choisir n'importe quels noms ou symboles pour les résultats.
En particulier, si nous avons une collection de projections étiquetées avec des symboles
d'un ensemble gamma quelconque,
et qu'elles satisfont la
même condition qu'avant, qui est qu'elles s'additionnent
à la matrice identité, alors nous avons une mesure projective
qui fonctionne exactement
de la même façon qu'avant.
La seule différence ici est que nous permettons
les résultats de mesure d'être des éléments de cet ensemble gamma au lieu des entiers de un à M.
Pour notre premier exemple d'une mesure projective, observons que
les mesures en base standard sont des mesures projectives.
Dans ce cas, l'ensemble des
résultats de la mesure est le même que l'ensemble des états classiques de quel que soit le système qui est mesuré.
Et l'ensemble des projections
qui décrit la mesure est cette collection ici, en supposant que sigma est
l'ensemble des états classiques
de notre système. Ce sont toutes des projections
et si on les additionne, on obtient la matrice identité, donc c'est une mesure projective valide
Pour voir comment ça fonctionne en
un peu plus de détail, supposons que nous ayons
un état arbitraire quelconque écrit sous la forme
que tu vois ici.
La probabilité pour que la
mesure donne le résultat A, selon la description
de tout à l'heure, est cette valeur ici,
qui est égale à la
valeur absolue au carré de l'entrée correspondante
du vecteur Psi, ce qui est ce qu'on attend.
Conditionné au résultat étant A, l'état du système devient cela, encore une fois, selon la
description de tout à l'heure.
Si on simplifie, nous n'obtenons pas
tout à fait l'état qu'on attend, qui est Ket A.
À la place on obtient Ket A
multiplié par un scalaire, et plus précisément, c'est un scalaire ayant
une valeur absolue égale à un,
donc c'est un nombre complexe
sur le cercle unité.
On appelle ça une phase globale et nous allons discuter des phases globales bientôt, mais pour l'instant en bref, cet
état est équivalent à Ket A.
Cette phase globale n'a
aucune signification du tout et nous verrons pourquoi
quand nous en arriverons à la discussion des phases globales.
Donc (peu clair) cette question des phases globales, dont nous parlerons dans un instant, nous voyons que les mesures en base standard
sont en fait des mesures projectives. Pour un autre exemple, qui est vraiment une extension
de l'exemple précédent,
si on effectue une mesure en base standard
sur un système X et qu'on ne fait rien à un système Y, comme nous en avons parlé
dans la leçon précédente,
c'est complètement équivalent
à mesurer le système X, Y.
Avec cette mesure projective
ici.
Nous avons ces projections correspondant aux états classiques de X et nous tensorisons avec l'identité sur Y
ce qui reflète le fait que
nous ne faisons rien à Y.
La description de comment
les mesures projectives fonctionnent en général nous dit
ce qui se passe dans cet exemple, et je te laisse
vérifier que c'est en fait
complètement équivalent à ce que nous avons discuté dans la leçon précédente.
C'est tout très bien parce que cette description de mesure projective est plus propre d'une certaine façon et on voit qu'elle s'inscrit dans
cette image plus générale.
WEBVTT
Voici encore un exemple d'une mesure projective.
Celui-ci est une mesure de deux Qubits.
Pour cette mesure
nous avons deux projections et donc deux résultats possibles
qui sont zéro et un.
Les projections sont définies
en termes des états de Bell comme tu le vois ici.
La première projection est
sur l'espace engendré par les trois états de Bell symétriques et la deuxième projection est
sur l'espace unidimensionnel
engendré par l'état Psi-, qui est l'antisymétrique, ou en d'autres termes celui
qui est multiplié
par un signe moins si on
effectue une opération swap sur les deux Qubits.
Nous verrons plus loin dans la série pourquoi c'est une mesure intéressante.
Pour l'instant, c'est juste un exemple
qui se connecte avec quelque chose que nous avons vu auparavant,
à savoir la base de Bell.
Une dernière note sur les mesures projectives c'est que chaque fois qu'on a
une mesure projective, on peut toujours implémenter cette mesure
en utilisant des opérations unitaires et
des mesures en base standard.
Pour cet exemple particulier de
mesure, par exemple, nous pouvons construire un quantum circuit qui implémente la mesure
comme tu le vois ici.
Nous imaginons que les deux
Qubits du haut sont les Qubits que nous mesurons avec
cette mesure projective et ce qu'on peut faire c'est
d'introduire un nouveau Qubit
qui commence initialisé
à l'état zéro. On effectue un gate Hadamard
suivi d'un gate Fredkin, suivi d'un autre gate Hadamard,
et si on mesure ce Qubit du bas en utilisant une mesure en base standard, l'effet sera exactement le même que si on avait mesuré les deux Qubits du haut
avec la mesure projective
de cet exemple.
Nous obtiendrons exactement les mêmes probabilités pour les deux résultats et l'effet que la mesure a sur les deux Qubits du haut
sera le même également.
Ce n'est pas du tout évident. Une analyse est nécessaire pour voir ça et cette analyse n'est pas montrée ici.
Comme je l'ai déjà suggéré, nous allons examiner de plus près
cette mesure particulière dans une leçon ultérieure et pour l'instant
c'est juste censé être un exemple.
Le point important à retenir est que quelque chose comme
ça est toujours possible pour n'importe quelle mesure projective, donc nous ne gagnons pas vraiment
de capacités supplémentaires
en introduisant des mesures projectives, mais c'est un concept très utile et nous parlerons souvent de mesures projectives
au fur et à mesure que nous continuons dans la série. La dernière partie de cette leçon porte sur quelques limitations importantes
de l'information quantique
et ce qu'on peut faire avec les quantum circuits.
La première limitation, qui n'est peut-être pas tant une limitation qu'une dégénérescence, concerne la question des phases globales
que j'ai mentionnée il y a peu. Voici la définition de ce qu'on entend quand on parle d'une phase globale.
Si nous avons deux
vecteurs d'état quantique, Psi et Phi, tels que l'un d'eux est
égal à l'autre multiplié par un certain nombre complexe alpha,
alors nous disons que les états
diffèrent par une phase globale ou alternativement qu'ils sont équivalents à une phase globale près.
Remarque que parce que les vecteurs d'état quantique ont une norme euclidienne égale à un, la seule façon que cette
équation puisse être vraie
c'est si la valeur absolue
de ce nombre complexe est égale à un, donc alpha
doit se trouver sur le cercle unité.
Imaginons que nous avons
deux états quantiques comme ça qui diffèrent par une phase globale et supposons que nous mesurons l'état Phi
avec une mesure en base standard.
La probabilité d'obtenir n'importe quel résultat A est donnée par cette expression ici, et si on substitue
alpha fois Psi pour Phi,
ce qu'on peut faire parce que nous
supposons qu'ils sont égaux, on obtient cette probabilité.
Et si on simplifie en utilisant le fait qu'alpha se trouve sur le
cercle unité complexe, on obtient cette probabilité.
Rappelle-toi que c'est la probabilité que mesurer Phi donne le résultat A, mais maintenant on voit que
c'est exactement la même chose que la probabilité que mesurer
Psi donne le résultat A,
donc il n'y a absolument
aucune différence du tout dans les probabilités des différents résultats pour les deux états.
Un argument similaire nous dit plus généralement que pour n'importe quelle mesure projective, les probabilités sont encore identiques.
Donc en mesurant, on ne peut pas
faire la différence entre deux états qui
diffèrent par une phase globale, même au sens statistique.
Finalement, si on applique n'importe quelle opération unitaire
à l'état Phi, alors encore une fois par substitution, ce qu'on obtiendra c'est exactement
le même nombre complexe alpha
multiplié à ce qu'on obtiendrait en appliquant la même opération unitaire
à l'état, Psi.
Donc les deux états différeront encore
par une phase globale.
La conclusion est que les deux états sont complètement indiscernables, donc il n'y a vraiment aucune
différence entre eux du tout
en termes de ce qu'on pourrait
possiblement apprendre sur eux en effectuant des opérations unitaires et des mesures et pour cette raison,
nous considérons ces deux
états comme équivalents ou si tu préfères, que ce sont juste deux représentations vectorielles possiblement différentes
du même état quantique.
Comme je l'ai dit au
début de la discussion, c'est essentiellement une dégénérescence
dans la façon dont les états quantiques sont décrits par les vecteurs d'état quantique.
En tout cas, ce que ça signifie c'est qu'on peut
simplement ignorer les phases globales comme nous l'avons fait effectivement quand nous avons décrit les mesures en base standard
WEBVTT
comme des mesures projectives. D'ailleurs, cette dégénérescence se produit seulement dans la description simplifiée
de l'information quantique.
Quand on décrit les états
quantiques en utilisant des matrices densité, comme nous le ferons dans la
troisième unité de la série, nous aurons une représentation matricielle unique
pour chaque état quantique. La question des phases globales
ne se pose tout simplement pas dans la description générale
de l'information quantique.
C'est un aspect supplémentaire attrayant
de la description générale de l'information quantique,
à laquelle je continue de faire allusion, mais quoi qu'il en soit, les phases globales ne nous dérangeront pas
parce qu'on peut simplement exercer
notre liberté de les ignorer.
Voici un exemple très rapide
juste pour s'assurer que la notion de phase globale est claire.
Si nous avons un état moins, et moins un fois un état moins, alors ces deux états
diffèrent par une phase globale, et en particulier nous avons
alpha égal à moins un.
D'un autre côté, si nous avons un état plus et un état moins, alors nous n'avons pas deux états
qui diffèrent par une phase globale.
Ce sont des vecteurs orthogonaux, donc ils sont linéairement indépendants.
Dire que deux vecteurs d'état quantique diffèrent par une phase globale
est équivalent à dire que les vecteurs sont linéairement dépendants,
donc ces vecteurs ne diffèrent certainement pas par une phase globale.
Il est vrai que la seule différence c'est que ce signe plus
se transforme en ce signe moins, mais c'est ce qu'on appelle une différence de phase relative.
C'est différent d'une phase globale parce que nous ne
multiplions pas le vecteur entier par un nombre complexe.
Et c'est cohérent avec le fait qu'on peut faire la différence
entre ces états, en particulier, si on
applique une opération Hadamard
et qu'on mesure ensuite, on verra un zéro si l'
état était un état plus et un si l'état était un état moins.
La prochaine limitation de l'information quantique que nous verrons dans cette leçon
est le théorème de non-clonage.
Voici un énoncé du
théorème de non-clonage et cet énoncé particulier
du théorème est assez concret et spécifique,
ce qui facilitera la discussion. Il y a d'autres façons plus générales de formuler le théorème de non-clonage,
mais nous nous concentrerons sur celui-ci pour l'instant.
Nous supposons que nous avons deux systèmes X et Y qui ont le même ensemble d'états classiques.
qui consiste en l'
entier de zéro à D-1 où D est au moins deux.
Ce n'est pas vraiment important quels noms ont les états classiques, mais en choisissant ces noms ça aidera à garder les choses simples.
Ce qui est le plus important
ici c'est qu'il y a au moins deux états classiques différents,
donc en d'autres termes, nous ne nous soucions pas du cas
trivial et sans intérêt
où nous n'avons qu'un seul état classique.
Ce que le théorème dit c'est qu'il n'existe pas d'opération unitaire U que nous pouvons appliquer à X, Y de sorte que si on initialise
Y à l'état zéro,
on copie ou clone effectivement
des états quantiques arbitraires de X.
Si on regarde cette
expression ici en isolation, ce qu'elle dit c'est que pour tous les choix d'un vecteur d'état quantique Psi de X,
appliquer U à Psi tensorisé
avec l'état zéro, nous donne Psi tenseur Psi, ou en d'autres termes deux
copies indépendantes de Psi,
donc c'est ce que ça voudrait dire si on pouvait cloner des états
quantiques et ce que le théorème dit c'est que ce n'est pas possible.
Tu peux penser à ça
en termes de circuits et ce que le théorème dit c'est
que tu ne pourras jamais proposer un gate ou un circuit
qui fonctionne comme tu le vois ici.
Où une copie de l'état Psi entre avec une collection
de Qubits initialisés et deux copies de Psi sont produites.
Tu peux faire ça pour certains
choix de l'état Psi, mais tu ne peux jamais proposer
un circuit qui fonctionne ainsi pour chaque état quantique Psi,
et c'est ce que le théorème dit.
Il est assez facile de prouver
ce théorème, en fait, ça se réduit essentiellement au fait que la transformation que nous
cherchons n'est pas linéaire,
mais les opérations unitaires sont
linéaires, donc ça ne peut tout simplement pas fonctionner.
Voici un argument un peu plus détaillé.
Supposons que nous avons une opération unitaire U qui clone les états
de la base standard, Ket 0 et Ket un.
Nous savons que les
états classiques zéro et un doivent appartenir à notre ensemble d'états classiques parce que D est au moins deux.
Mais ça signifie par linéarité
que si X est dans un état plus, qu'on peut écrire comme ça,
alors le résultat est cette combinaison linéaire de ces deux états ici.
Cependant, ce n'est pas le bon comportement. L'exigence sur U c'est que
U clone est un état plus,
ce qui signifie qu'on doit
avoir cette équation ici satisfaite.
Ces deux états ne sont pas les
mêmes et donc ça ne fonctionne pas et c'est tout ce qu'il y a à dire.
Juste quelques remarques supplémentaires
sur le théorème de non-clonage.
D'abord, cet énoncé du
théorème de non-clonage est absolu dans un certain sens.
Il dit simplement qu'une opération unitaire U qui fonctionne exactement comme
ça n'existe pas.
Tu pourrais donc te demander si
il existe une opération unitaire U qui
fait ça approximativement par rapport à une certaine façon de décrire
WEBVTT
une approximation de l'énoncé. Il existe différentes
notions d'approximation qui pourraient nous intéresser
et nous en verrons quelques-unes
dans la troisième unité de la série, mais pour ces différentes
notions d'approximation,
il y a des énoncés quantitatifs
du théorème de non-clonage qui imposent des limites strictes sur à quel point tu peux approximativement cloner.
Une deuxième remarque c'est que copier ou cloner des états de la base standard
est certainement possible.
Par exemple, un gate Controlled NOT copie les états de la base standard d'un Qubit.
Ça ne contredit pas
le théorème de non-clonage. Le point c'est que le clonage au sens du théorème de non-clonage exige
que ça fonctionne non seulement
pour les états de la base standard
mais pour tous les états.
Un gate Controlled NOT
ne clone certainement pas un état plus par exemple.
Et finalement, il vaut la peine de souligner qu'il existe aussi un théorème de non-clonage pour
les états probabilistes.
Ce n'est tout simplement pas quelque chose
dont les gens parlent ou s'intéressent.
Si quelqu'un choisit aléatoirement
un bit, par exemple, pour une façon arbitraire quelconque d'
affecter des probabilités aux deux valeurs et
te donne ensuite ce bit,
bien sûr il n'y a aucun moyen pour toi d'obtenir deux échantillons indépendants
de ce bit aléatoire.
Tu ne sais tout simplement pas quelles
sont les probabilités.
Tu peux copier le bit tout comme un Controlled NOT
copie les états de la base standard, mais ce n'est pas la même chose que cloner l'état probabiliste.
Tu n'as tout simplement pas assez
d'information pour faire ça. Quel que soit le bit aléatoire qui t'a été donné ne te dit pas quelles
étaient les probabilités.
C'est juste un bit.
L'impossibilité de cloner
un état probabiliste découle exactement du même raisonnement que dans le cadre quantique.
Le clonage est un processus non linéaire, alors que les opérations probabilistes, tout comme les opérations unitaires, sont linéaires.
Bref, ce n'est pas surprenant
qu'on ne puisse pas cloner un état probabiliste et
d'une certaine façon ce n'est pas aussi intéressant que le fait qu'on ne puisse pas
cloner un état quantique,
mais le point c'est simplement d'observer que ce n'est pas un phénomène
uniquement quantique.
La dernière limitation
de l'information quantique dont nous discuterons dans cette leçon c'est qu'il n'est pas possible
de discriminer parfaitement
deux états quantiques qui ne sont pas orthogonaux.
Une autre façon de dire ça
c'est que si deux états quantiques peuvent être parfaitement discriminés, alors ils doivent être orthogonaux.
Ce qu'on entend quand on parle
d'une discrimination parfaite de deux états quantiques, Psi et Phi, c'est qu'il y a une façon
de les distinguer
sans aucune chance d'erreur.
En termes du modèle de quantum circuit, on peut exprimer ça comme tu
le vois ici sur l'écran.
Nous avons une opération unitaire U, qui pourrait être implémentée
comme un quantum circuit ou on pourrait juste penser à U de manière abstraite
comme une opération unitaire
et en entrée forcée U prend soit l'état Psi soit l'état Phi
avec un ensemble de Qubits initialisés, que tu peux penser comme des Qubits d'espace de travail qui aident d'une certaine façon dans ce
processus de discrimination.
Après que U est appliqué, le Qubit du haut est mesuré par rapport à une mesure en base standard et voici la partie de discrimination parfaite.
Si l'état d'entrée était Psi, alors la mesure doit
donner le résultat zéro, 100% du temps, et si
l'état d'entrée était Phi,
alors la mesure doit
donner le résultat un, encore une fois avec 100% de chance.
Ce n'est pas important quel est l'état
de ces autres Qubits après que U a été appliqué.
Tout ce qui importe c'est ce seul bit qu'on obtient de la mesure parce que c'est le bit qui nous dit lequel des deux états on a commencé avec.
Pour certains choix d'états, Psi et Phi, il sera possible d'effectuer une discrimination parfaite comme
ça et pour d'autres non.
Et ce que nous allons observer c'est que
si c'est possible de faire ça, alors Psi et Phi doivent
être des états orthogonaux
et ça signifie que si Phi et
Psi ne sont pas orthogonaux, tu ne peux pas les discriminer parfaitement.
Voyons donc pourquoi une discrimination parfaite implique l'orthogonalité.
Nous allons commencer par écrire deux équations qui expriment ce que ces
deux diagrammes expriment.
Si on pense à l'état quantique, on obtient après avoir appliqué U à
un ensemble de Qubits initialisés ensemble avec l'état Psi,
on voit qu'il doit
avoir cette forme ici, où Pi zéro est un vecteur d'état quantique représentant l'état
de tous ces Qubits
sauf le premier. Nous n'avons aucune information
sur cet état quantique, Pi zéro, ça pourrait être n'importe quoi,
mais nous savons que l'état entier
doit ressembler à ça parce que c'est la seule
façon que la mesure soit garantie de donner le
résultat zéro, 100% du temps.
Et nous avons une équation analogue pour la deuxième.
Cette fois le Qubit du haut
doit être dans l'état un et similaire à Pi zéro, l'
état Pi un pourrait être n'importe quoi.
Et en plus de n'avoir
aucune information sur Pi un, nous ne savons rien non plus
sur la relation entre Pi zéro et Pi un.
Pour tout ce qu'on sait, ce sont juste deux
états quantiques arbitraires.
WEBVTT
Ce qu'on peut faire ensuite c'est
multiplier les deux côtés de ces équations des
deux côtés par U dague, c'est-à-dire la transposée conjuguée de U.
Et si on fait ça, on obtient les deux équations
que tu vois ici.
Nous utilisons le fait que U dague fois U est la matrice identité.
C'est pourquoi on ne voit pas U ou U dague du côté gauche de l'une ou l'autre équation.
Et maintenant on peut considérer le produit intérieur entre Psi et Phi.
C'est le même que le produit intérieur
de Psi et Phi multiplié par le produit intérieur
de l'état L zéro avec lui-même
parce que le produit intérieur de
n'importe quel état avec lui-même est un et ça inclut l'état L zéro.
Et maintenant si on regarde nos deux équations, on voit que cette expression ici est égale au produit intérieur des vecteurs
représentés par les deux équations. Et en particulier c'est le produit intérieur entre les membres gauches
de ces équations.
Donc on peut tout aussi bien
exprimer ce produit intérieur comme le produit intérieur des vecteurs représentés par les membres droits
de ces équations,
parce que le membre gauche est
égal au membre droit pour les deux équations.
Donc on obtient cette expression ici, qui est le produit intérieur
des deux membres droits des équations ou de façon équivalente,
c'est la transposée conjuguée du premier multipliée au second.
U fois U dague est égal
à la matrice identité, parce que U est unitaire et donc ça disparaît.
Et on peut simplifier juste un peu pour obtenir le produit de
ces produits intérieurs.
Rappelle-toi maintenant que nous ne savons rien sur la relation
entre Pi zéro et Pi un, donc nous ne savons pas quel
est leur produit intérieur.
C'est un mystère pour nous. Mais quel que soit ce que c'est, on le multiplie par le produit intérieur de Ket 0 et Ket un, qui est zéro.
Donc le résultat final c'est qu'on
obtient la valeur zéro, mais c'est ce qu'on voulait montrer, le produit intérieur entre
Psi et Phi est égal à zéro.
Donc les deux états sont orthogonaux.
Donc ne te donne pas la peine d'essayer
de discriminer parfaitement deux états quantiques non orthogonaux, tu ne peux tout simplement pas le faire.
Il y a une réciproque à
l'énoncé que nous venons de prouver, qui est que les états quantiques orthogonaux peuvent toujours être parfaitement discriminés,
et ce n'est pas trop difficile à
voir si on utilise un fait que j'ai mentionné plus tôt dans la leçon.
Plus précisément si Psi et
Phi sont des états orthogonaux, alors une chose qu'on peut faire c'est de choisir n'importe quelle matrice unitaire U
dont les deux premières colonnes
sont les deux états.
Nous savons qu'il est toujours
possible de faire ça et ça n'a pas d'importance
pour les besoins de cette tâche exactement comment cette matrice unitaire est choisie.
Tout ce qui est important c'est que ce sont les deux premières colonnes.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de Qubits supplémentaires. Si on applique simplement U aux
deux états possibles, alors on obtiendra ces
deux résultats possibles.
Et si on mesure le Qubit le plus en haut, qui rappelle-toi est le Qubit le plus à droite, alors on obtiendra un zéro ou un un
selon l'état avec lequel on a commencé.
Alternativement, on peut envisager
une mesure projective avec les résultats zéro à un
définie comme tu le vois ici.
dans ce cas, la mesure
dépend en fait uniquement de Psi.
Cette mesure discrimine parfaitement
Psi de n'importe quel état qui est orthogonal à Psi.
Si on mesure Psi par rapport à cette mesure projective, alors on obtiendra le résultat
zéro avec probabilité un comme ces équations le révèlent.
Et pour n'importe quel état Phi
qui est orthogonal à Psi, on obtiendra le résultat
un avec probabilité un.
Je ne vais pas passer en revue les
détails de ces calculs, mais si tu es intéressé, je t'encourage à parcourir
les détails toi-même.
Et c'est la fin de la leçon trois. Nous avons couvert beaucoup de
matière dans cette leçon, y compris les quantum circuits,
les produits intérieurs et l'orthonormalité, les projections et les mesures projectives, le fait que les phases globales n'ont pas d'importance,
le théorème de non-clonage, et le fait que les états non orthogonaux ne peuvent pas être parfaitement discriminés tandis que les états orthogonaux le peuvent.
J'espère que tu te joindras à moi pour
la quatrième leçon bientôt, qui est la dernière leçon dans
la première unité de la série.
Dans la quatrième leçon, nous parlerons de trois
exemples très importants, la téléportation, le codage superdense,
et l'inégalité CHSH ou le jeu CHSH comme on le décrit parfois.
Au revoir jusqu'à la prochaine,